[Applause]
the defending Champion U.S women's
soccer team is going into their first
World Cup since agreeing to share their
prize money with the U.S men's team
it's just going to be very competitive
it's going to be
um the most watched World Cup it's it's
going to be the best one yet the
Americans are going after an
unprecedented third consecutive World
Cup Championship but that's not the only
goal on players Minds there's still a
big discrepancy between the men's prize
money from FIFA and the women's and to
me that's unacceptable FIFA is a
non-profit organization this year
they've more than tripled the total
prize money for the Women's World Cup
compared to 2019 but the 110 million
dollars announced by FIFA in March is a
fraction of what the men received just
last year we still have a lot of fight
left and there's a lot of room for
improvement
I'm
[Music]
us is the most successful team in FIFA
Women's World Cup history winning the
tournament four times the only team with
more World Cup gold is Brazil's men's
team with five titles
U.S forward Kristen press won
back-to-back titles in 2015 and 2019 but
has been sidelined for a year with an
injury when we won the World Cup in 2015
it became abundantly clear that the way
that we were being valued by our
employer did not match the way that we
were valued by the World Press is one of
the players who filed a lawsuit against
the U.S soccer Federation for gender
discrimination just ahead of the 2019
tournament in France when you play in a
World Cup you really shut out the world
you have to be dedicated and focused
entirely on your craft on what happens
between the lines but yet we had that
drum beat in the back of our minds that
this was for something bigger the
lawsuit alleges a number of inequalities
compared to the men's team including pay
disparities training conditions and game
promotion
in its response the U.S soccer
Federation argued that the men's and
women's team were not comparable because
of their different schedules obligations
and compensation and that the women's
team had no counterparts on the men's
team the U.S soccer federation did not
reply to a request for comment
after a three-year legal battle the
players and U.S soccer reached a 24
million dollar settlement both the men's
and the women's team reach new labor
deals with U.S soccer that aligned the
team's pay the two teams also agreed to
pull and share their prize money from
their respective World Cups
[Music]
foreign
this year's tournament will include more
teams more prize money and more Fanfare
than ever before
the Women's World Cup debuted in 1991 61
years after the first men's tournament
in recent years the women's event has
made large gains in viewers but its
prize money remains far behind the men's
tournament
FIFA says the 2019 Women's World Cup in
France Drew 1.1 billion viewers
worldwide 31 of the almost 3.6 billion
people who watched the 2018 men's World
Cup in Russia but it awarded the women
chest 7.5 of the 400 million dollar
prize money that had awarded the men
in June FIFA announced that for the
first time in a women's world cup a
portion of the prize money would be
earmarked specifically for the players
in the past federations generally
decided how much of the prize money to
give players in a statement FIFA
president Johnny Infantino called the
distribution model unprecedented each
player will earn a minimum of thirty
thousand dollars with the women on the
winning team getting two hundred and
seventy thousand dollars having them
direct payments to the players is huge I
mean it's a life-changing thing for some
of these players the payment model for
2023 was welcomed by Thief Pro an
umbrella organization that represents 65
000 men's and women soccer players and
their unions worldwide the biggest thing
probably at the minute is making sure
that the uh the agreement the conditions
the compensation system that we were
able to put in place together with FIFA
are actually being implemented
because of a unique mechanism in their
collective bargaining agreements
whatever the American women win this
year they'll share with the U.S men's
team it works like this let's say the US
women take first place FIFA has allotted
4.29 million dollars in prize money for
the 2023 winning member Association in
this example that's U.S soccer
each of the 23 players on the roster
gets 270 thousand dollars that's another
6.21 million dollars combined that's
10.5 million dollars from FIFA for
winning the Women's World Cup for the
Americans that money would get pulled
with what the U.S men's team won for
reaching The Knockout stage in their
World Cup last year for a total of 23.5
million dollars a portion of that goes
to the U.S soccer Federation and the
men's and women's teams split the rest
[Music]
says it's modernizing football to be
Global accessible and inclusive in all
aspects
in a video posted on social media just
days before the 2023 World Cup kickoff
players from co-host country Australia
highlighted the Gap in FIFA prize money
between the men's and women's
competitions collective bargaining has
allowed us to ensure we now get the same
conditions as the socceroos with one
exception FIFA will still only offer
women one quarter as much prize money as
men for the same achievement FIFA says
it's aiming for equality in the prize
money for the 2026-2027 World Cup cycle
that would be a 300 increase for the
women if the men's prize money remains
at 440 million we're seeing growth
across the globe in the women's game at
a league level at an international level
the support's there and I think that is
going to make it the the best World Cup
ever
foreign